Picture the land around any given interstate exit, the massive concrete overpasses, the bowtie loop deloops of on and off ramps. In California, the agency that maintains the land around our highways is the California Department of Transportation or CalTrans. In 2017, CalTrans counted 7,000 homeless encampments next to California roads. Okay, now zoom in on one of these encampments. In Berkeley, California, off of Interstate 80 at the University exit. There are about 70 people living there,
想象一下任意一个州际公路出口周围的土地、巨大的混凝土立交桥，以及上下匝道的蝶形环状立交。在加利福尼亚州，维护我们高速公路旁土地的机构是加州交通运输局，简称加州交通局。2017年，加州交通局统计出加州道路旁有7000个无家可归者营地。好的，现在把镜头拉近到其中一个营地。在加利福尼亚州伯克利市，位于80号州际公路大学路出口附近。那里大约有70人居住，
scattered around intense and makeshift structures. For years now, CalTrans has been posting notices for the people camped at this exit to vacate. And every couple of weeks, they attempt to enforce the notices by coming in with police and cleaning crews and confiscating any belongings people can't pack up and move in time.
散落在帐篷和临时搭建的建筑周围。多年来，加州交通局一直贴出告示，要求在这个出口露营的人限期搬走。每隔几个星期，他们就会试图通过警察和清洁人员进入现场来强制执行这些告示，并没收人们来不及收拾和带走的任何财物。
It's always incredibly stressful for the people who live there. We gotta break down his house. That's important. We break down the house. Can you move that out the way? No, no, no, he doesn't need to move that out the way? He doesn't need to move that way. And then after the police and Cal Trans maintenance Cruz leave, the homeless campers take the belongings they've salvaged and move right back to the same spots they were in before.
对于住在那里的人来说，这总是极其痛苦的。“我们得拆了他的房子。这很重要。我们拆了房子。你能把那个移开吗？不，不，不，他不需要把那个移开吗？他不需要那样移开。”然后，在警察和加州交通局的维护人员离开后，流浪露营者们就会带上他们抢救出来的财物，重新搬回他们之前呆过的老地方。
A couple weeks later, Cal Trans comes again over and over, rinse and repeat. One of the people living in this encampment in Berkeley is Kate Cody, who goes by her initials, KC. I'm in it KC last year in October when it was starting to get chilly. The listener's don't know is this is a very misty and cold day. It almost, you know, yeah, that's foggy, huh? Yeah. Casey has long silver hair, so bright,
几个星期后，加州交通局又来了，一次又一次，周而复始。住在伯克利这个营地的人之一是凯特·科迪，大家按她的名字首字母叫她KC。去年10月天气开始变冷时，我遇到了KC。听众们不知道的是，这是一个雾气蒙蒙且寒冷的日子。它几乎，你知道，是的，起雾了，对吧？是的。凯西有着一头长长的银发，如此闪亮，
it almost looks like platinum blonde. And narrow, kind of mischievous eyes. You could mistake her for a hippie, but she's surlier than most. She wears a leather overcoat. She sometimes growls at people. She'll read any book she can get her hands on. I really can't go to sleep without them.
几乎看起来像白金金发。还有一双狭长的、有点调皮的眼睛。你可能会把她误认为是一个嬉皮士，但她比大多数人都更脾气暴躁。她穿着一件皮革外套。她有时会对人咆哮。她会阅读她能拿到手的任何书。“我真的离不开它们，否则无法入睡。”
And now I've gotten past the well past the point where I fall asleep with the book on my nose and break my glasses. The last time CalTrans came through for a sweep of the encampment, a bunch of cases belongings were thrown into a dump truck. But she saved some precious items. And when you lost all your stuff from when CalTrans did they get books or they were writing with beads. She saved her books and her beads. Casey makes beaded jewelry that she sells in an Etsy store. But CalTrans threw away her tent and her bed. For a couple weeks after that she slept under a cast aside boat sail. Now she has a new tent, which she's set up on the shoulder of the off ramp right next to the stop sign.
而现在我已经过了那个会把书顶在鼻子上睡觉并把眼镜压碎的阶段了。加州交通局上次来清扫营地时，凯西的一堆物品被扔进了自卸卡车。但她抢救了一些珍贵的物品。当加州交通局清理时，你失去了所有的东西，是书吗，还是他们用珠子做的？她保住了她的书和珠子。凯西制作串珠首饰，并在Etsy网店出售。但加州交通局扔掉了她的帐篷和床。在此后的几个星期里，她睡在一块废弃的船帆下面。现在她有了一个新帐篷，搭在靠近停车标志的匝道边缘。
And she'd like to be left alone. Do you think that the cities should like that anyone has the right to camp if they don't have a tent? No, but they do. All we want to know is we don't want to break the law. But we have to live some lives and have to sleep on face just like I need to live. And what were Casey's options besides living in a tent next to the highway? She seemed to feel that renting her own apartment in Berkeley was completely out of reach. You know, they're renting the not apartments, not bedrooms, beds for 1200 a month in the college?
她希望能独自呆着。你认为城市应该允许任何人，如果没有帐篷的话，都有露营的权利吗？不，但他们确实这么做了。我们只想知道，我们不想违法。但我们必须过日子，必须在某个地方睡觉，就像我需要生存一样。除了住在高速公路旁的帐篷里，凯西还有什么选择？她似乎觉得在伯克利租一间自己的公寓完全是遥不可及的。“你知道，在大学附近，他们租的不是公寓，不是卧室，是床位，每月1200美元？”
That's outrageous. Kasey had about $900 a month coming in through social security. And it did seem unlikely given her age 66, and the fact that she can only walk very slowly using a walker, that she was going to be able to get a job to increase her income. She tried staying in shelters, but hated the lack of privacy. I just can't, I cannot handle that at all. Plus, most shelters don't allow pets, and Casey has a scragly little black and white dog named Eva who rarely leaves her side.
这太离谱了。凯西通过社会保障每月有大约900美元的收入。考虑到她66岁的年龄，以及她只能用助行器非常缓慢地行走的现状，她似乎不太可能找到一份工作来增加收入。她尝试过住在收容所，但讨厌那里缺乏隐私。“我简直无法忍受，我根本无法应付那种情况。”此外，大多数收容所不允许带宠物，而凯西有一只邋遢的小黑白狗叫伊娃，它很少离开她身边。
But there was still another option. Casey has a son named Lonnie who lives in the mountains of Colorado. The two of them were estranged for most of their lives, for complicated reasons that I don't fully understand. But about five years ago, they reunited, and they really care about each other. Lonnie doesn't have much money either, but he told his mom,
但仍有另一种选择。凯西有一个儿子叫朗尼，住在科罗拉多州的山区。由于复杂的原因，他们母子俩大半生都处于疏离状态，这些原因我并不是很完全理解。但大约五年前，他们团聚了，而且他们真的很关心对方。朗尼也没有多少钱，但他对妈妈说：
move here to my town and I'll help you. It's cheap here, we'll get you a place, and you can stay at my house until you find your own. But so far, Casey hasn't taken Lonnie up on his offer to come live in Colorado. I really hate you. I'm not playing about hating the cold. I really hate the cold. If I never see a snowflake again in my life, I'll be so happy. I think a lot of people would be surprised that you wouldn't take advantage of it. Why, should I take advantage of it?
“搬到我这里来吧，我会帮你的。这里很便宜，我们会给你找个地方，在你找到自己的住处之前，你可以住在我家里。”但到目前为止，凯西还没有接受朗尼让她去科罗拉多生活的提议。“我真的很讨厌你。我不是在开玩笑说我讨厌寒冷。我真的讨厌寒冷。如果我这辈子再也见不到一片雪花，我会高兴死的。”我想很多人会惊讶你居然不利用这个机会。为什么我要利用这个机会？
We support support for a lifetime. I'm slowly reconnecting. And if I move to a very small town in Colorado, when you're no one, we don't know each other well enough yet. Casey told me that she thought of Lonnie as an escape hatch, but if she wouldn't use her escape hatch to escape the constant sweeps by CalTrans, or the difficulty of living 10 feet from a busy interstate off-ramp, it was hard for me to imagine when she would use it.
我们支持……支持一辈子。我正在慢慢重新建立联系。如果我搬到一个科罗拉多非常的小镇，当你在那里谁也不是时，我们还不够了解彼此。凯西告诉我，她把朗尼视为一个逃生舱，但如果她不愿利用这个逃生舱来逃避加州交通局不断的清扫，或者逃避住在繁忙的州际公路匝道旁10英尺处的艰难生活，我很难想象她什么时候才会使用它。
Use said he's an escape hatch, and so I was trying to figure out the situation in which you might use your escape hatch. I don't know. I really know it. He's just like knowing it's there. Yeah. Yeah. Like knowing he's there. When Casey and I had this conversation, I didn't think anyone would live in a tent by an interstate if they had another option, but it's more complicated than that.
你说他是一个逃生舱，所以我一直在试图弄清楚你可能会使用这个逃生舱的情况。我不知道。我真的知道。他就像……只要知道他在那儿就行。对。是的。就像知道他在那儿一样。当凯西和我进行这次对话时，我原本认为如果还有别的选择，没有人会愿意住在高速公路旁的帐篷里，但事情比这更复杂。
What I came to believe is that in general, people are where they are not necessarily because they literally have no other choice, although for some that is the case. But because like any human making a decision, they weighed out the choices and a tent by the side of the road seemed the least bad. I think it's why you do occasionally hear people say, I chose to be out here, which by the way you do here sometimes. I believe what people mean is is I chose this off a short
我渐渐相信，总的来说，人们身处他们所在的地方，不一定是因为他们真的别无选择，尽管对某些人来说确实如此。而是因为就像任何做出决定的普通人一样，他们权衡了各种选择，路边的帐篷似乎是其中最不坏的一个。我想这也是为什么你偶尔会听到有人说“我选择呆在这里”，顺便说一句，你有时确实会听到这种说法。我相信人们的意思是：我从一个糟糕的选择清单中选择了这个，
list of lousy options, but there's still agency in that, and agency is precious. In any case, for KC, the encampment was the best of the lousy options. For reasons, I was just beginning to understand. For reasons, I was just beginning to understand. In fact, for Casey, what they can't provide it to her was so important that even when she was found to be vulnerable enough, to make it to the top of the list, and be offered a new way out, it would be hard for her to accept it. This is according to need, chapter five. Casey is kind of a tough guy, but it's a toughness that covers up a lot of trauma. I get emotional, I get, I get, I get, I get about everything.
但这里面仍然有自主权，而自主权是珍贵的。无论如何，对KC来说，这个营地是那些糟糕选择中最好的一个。出于种种原因，我才刚刚开始理解。出于种种原因，我才刚刚开始理解。事实上，对凯西来说，营地能提供给她的东西是如此重要，以至于当人们发现她足够脆弱、能够排到名单的最前端并获得一条新的出路时，她也很难接受它。这是根据《需求》第五章。凯西有点像个女汉子，但这是一种掩盖了大量创伤的坚强。“我变得情绪化，我变得，我变得，我变得，我对一切都……”
I've seen you. Happy, I know, I just feel very bad because I'm just like, I get, I get, I get, I get about everything. I've seen you. Happy? Yes. I know, I just, I feel very bad because then it's like, you know, blew my cover. What's your cover? Tough. I guess, I don't know. Kasey grew up in New Jersey and ran away from home as a teenager, leaving behind a mother
“我见过你。”“高兴的，我知道，我只是感觉很糟糕，因为我就是那种，我变得，我变得，我变得，我对一切都……”“我见过你。”“高兴的？是的。我知道，我只是，我觉得很糟糕，因为那样的话，就好像，你知道，暴露了我的伪装。”“你的伪装是什么？”“坚强。我猜，我不知道。”凯西在新泽西州长大，十几岁时离家出走，留下了一个
that she says was abusive. I ruined my mother's life because I was born in Casey told me once. But mostly she just can't talk about her mom at all. As a young adult, Casey made her way out to California. She's done some hard living. She was stabbed once. She spent some time in prison. She was addicted to heroin, although she hasn't used in seven years. I'm still junky. That doesn't change. It's a physical thing.
据她说虐待过她的母亲。“我毁了我母亲的生活，因为我出生了，”凯西曾对我说。但大多数时候，她根本无法谈论她的母亲。作为一名年轻成年人，凯西来到了加利福尼亚。她过过一段艰难的生活。她曾被人刺伤过一次。她在监狱里度过了一段时间。她曾对海洛因上瘾，尽管她已经七年没碰过了。“我仍然是个瘾君子。这不会改变。这是一种生理上的东西。”
It doesn't change. And I'll have to do it three days in a row. And there I am. For much of her life, Casey had steady housing and income as an in-home health aid. But she's no stranger to unconventional living situations. And to some degree, she's welcomed them.
它不会改变。我只要连续三天碰它，我就又陷进去了。在凯西的大部分时间里，她作为一名居家健康助理，有着稳定的住房和收入。但她对非传统的生活状况并不陌生。在某种程度上，她还挺欢迎这些状况。
She's lived in warehouses and school buses, and for a long time, she lived in a community of people that built little wooden shacks on top of an old landfill right next to the bay. Don't picture a dump, though. There were some chunks of concrete and rebar scattered around, but this landfill had mostly been covered over with crabgrass.
她住在仓库和校车里，很长一段时间里，她生活在一个社区里，那里的人们在紧挨着海湾的一个旧垃圾填埋场上面建造了简陋的小木屋。不过，别把这想象成一个垃圾场。周围散落着一些混凝土块和钢筋，但这个垃圾场大部分已经被多年生狗牙根覆盖了。
And from its windy shores, you could watch the sunsetting behind the Golden Gate Bridge. Casey was kind of a queen bee among the landfillions as they called themselves. Her neighbors respected her and she felt like she had a role there. I found a film from that time on YouTube. It's less than 10 years old but Casey looks so much younger and healthier. Her cheeks are plump and rosy and she's moving around easily. She coats a big meal for everyone in the outdoor kitchen.
从它风大的海岸上，你可以看着太阳在金门大桥后面落下。在这些自称为“垃圾场居民”的人当中，凯西有点像女王蜂。她的邻居们尊重她，她觉得自己在那里扮演着一个角色。我在YouTube上找到了那段时期的视频。那还不到10年，但凯西看起来要年轻健康得多。她的双颊饱满红润，行动自如。她在户外厨房为每个人做了一顿丰盛的大餐。
I'm taking the chicken breast fillets and I pounded them out and stuck them with cornbread and sausage stuffing and I'm baking them and I serve them with a white gravy and salad. In this clip she was making food for a birthday party they were throwing for Chompi, one of the landfills many dogs. Happy birthday to you! Happy birthday to Chompi! Happy birthday to you! Happy birthday to you! After the city of Albany forced the land fillions to leave in 2014, the land was turned into a park that Bay Area residents know as the Albany bulb, and Casey moved into a broken down RV where she stayed a few years.
“我把鸡胸肉片拿来敲扁，塞进玉米面包和香肠填料，然后烤着吃，配上白肉汁和沙拉。”在这段视频中，她正在为一个生日派对准备食物，那是他们为“冲皮”（Chompi）举办的派对，“冲皮”是垃圾填埋场众多的狗之一。“祝你生日快乐！祝冲皮生日快乐！祝你生日快乐！祝你生日快乐！”在奥尔巴尼市于2014年强迫垃圾填埋场的居民离开后，这片土地变成了一个公园，被湾区居民称为“奥尔巴尼球茎”（Albany Bulb），凯西搬进了一辆破旧的房车里，并在那里住了几年。
But eventually she had to leave there too, which is when she moved to the encampment in Berkeley next to I-80 where I met her. Some of her old friends from the landfill were already living there, so it felt safe. The landfill loomed so large in Casey's mind that I sometimes felt like even though she was in a considerably worse situation now. Part of her was still there, we're still looking for what she had there. But where that police had been quiet and peaceful, now Casey lived five feet from a stop sign, so close to the road that the drivers could easily see inside.
但最终她也不得不离开那里，于是她搬到了伯克利靠近80号公路的营地，我在那里遇到了她。她在垃圾填埋场的一些老朋友已经住在那里了，所以她觉得很安全。垃圾填埋场在凯西的脑海里留下了如此深刻的印象，以至于我有时觉得，尽管她现在的处境明显更糟，但她的一部分仍然留在那儿，仍然在寻找她在那儿时拥有的东西。然而，曾经安静和平的地方不见了，现在凯西住在离停车标志5英尺远的地方，离道路如此之近，以至于司机们可以轻易看到里面。
And the spot was prone to flooding in the rainy season, which had arrived. It's November, it's cold and damp and raining, and Casey is sick inside of her tent. You feeling really bad? You're good. I'm sorry. Suddenly, you got so cold. I'm so good. Just outside, Casey's neighbor Sarah is trying to make sure Casey's tent doesn't flood
而且这个地方在雨季很容易被淹，而雨季已经来临了。那是11月，天气又冷又潮湿还在下雨，凯西在帐篷里生病了。“你觉得真的很糟糕吗？你很好。对不起。”“突然之间，你变得这么冷。我很好。”就在外面，凯西的邻居莎拉正试图确保凯西的帐篷不会被雨水淹了。
from all the rain. Sarah's tent is up on wooden pallets so that the water can drain under it. But Cacy's isn't. Why isn't Drining true of the tent? Hey, hi. Oh. We're trying to get the water to flow down to the road. Last year when it was raining,
莎拉的帐篷搭在木托盘上，这样水就能从下面排走。但凯西的却没有。“为什么水没有从帐篷下面流走？”“嘿，嗨。哦。”“我们正试图让水流向路边。”去年下雨的时候，
this turned into a, it was a lake. I mean, literally a lake. Even if Casey wasn't sick, she'd need help getting palettes. Her mobility just isn't good enough to do this kind of chore on her own. So she relies on people like Sarah for help. I'm frustrated. I can't put my fingers.
这里变成了一个……这是一个湖。我的意思是，简直就是一个湖。即使凯西没有生病，她也需要帮助来搬运木托盘。她的行动能力实在不够好，无法独自完成这种杂务。所以她依靠像莎拉这样的人来帮忙。“我很沮丧。我没法动弹我的手指。”
It's just difficult. It's just a difficult day. Sarah goes inside of her tent to talk to her boyfriend, Zach. Casey needs pallets and she's sick and also needs water, or she tells him. And you need to go get it. Zach is smoking something. I don't know what, but not a cigarette. And he's not interested in helping right now. No, Zach, save it.
这太难了。这只是艰难的一天。莎拉走进她的帐篷和她的男朋友扎克说话。凯西需要木托盘，而且她生病了，还需要水，或者她告诉他。而你需要去拿。扎克在抽着什么东西。我不知道是什么，但不是香烟。他现在对帮忙不感兴趣。“不，扎克，省省吧。”
You're just admit that you're just a douchebag. You have no manners. Now you won't help Casey get water. You want me to do it, as I'm digging a ditch to save her 10. Sarah and Zach continue to fight, and then finally Sarah says, that's it, she's had it with the whole thing. She doesn't finish digging the ditch, doesn't go get Casey pallets or water. She just goes to another part of the encampment, to someone else's tent, to decompress. I'm sorry you guys, I can't do this, I'm about to leave.
“你只是承认你是个混蛋。你一点礼貌都没有。现在你不肯帮凯西弄水。你想让我去做，因为我正在挖沟来保护她的帐篷。”莎拉和扎克继续争吵，最后莎拉说，够了，她对这一切都受够了。她没有挖完沟，也没有去给凯西拿木托盘或水。她只是去了营地的另一个地方，去别人的帐篷里放松心情。“对不起，伙计们，我做不到这个，我正要离开。”
I thought a lot about this interaction afterwards. How a normal, everyday thing for most of us, like rain, can turn into a crisis in the camp. These little crises happen constantly. It means that everyone is stressed all the time and people fight, and sometimes even people with good intentions, like Sarah, just don't have the bandwidth to do what needs to be done. Researchers have actually studied this. The way stress and scarcity erode our ability to make good decisions and solve problems,
事后我思考了很多关于这次互动的事情。像下雨这样对我们大多数人来说普通得不能再普通的事情，如何在营地里变成一场危机。这些小危机不断发生。这意味着每个人无时无刻不在承受压力，人们会吵架，有时甚至像莎拉这样出于好意的人，也没有精力和带宽去做需要完成的事情。研究人员实际上已经对此进行过研究。压力和匮乏侵蚀我们做出好的决策和解决问题的能力的方式，
it's a thing. Still, eventually someone will get Casey water. If her tent floods, someone will help. Casey depends on her neighbors and the encampment for everything. Neighbors run to the store for her and bring her food. Her friends sit, cleans her tent for her. Sometimes it's just friends being friends. Other times she barters with people. It's hard for Casey to get rid of her own garbage, for example. The guy who comes pick up my recycling takes my garbage with him to deal with it.
这是真实存在的。不过，最终会有人给凯西送水。如果她的帐篷被淹了，会有人来帮忙。凯西的一切都依赖于她的邻居和营地。邻居们帮她跑腿买东西，给她带吃的。她的朋友坐着，帮她清理帐篷。有时只是朋友之间的互相帮忙。其他时候她与人进行物物交换。例如，凯西很难处理自己的垃圾。那个来收我回收物的人顺便把我的垃圾也带走了，帮我处理掉。
Yes, deal with it. What does he get out of a deal? He gets to recycling. He gets like your cans and stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Look, I don't want to romanticize encampments. They're hard places to live.
是的，处理掉。他从中得到了什么？他得到了回收物。他得到了像你的易拉罐之类的东西。对。是的。听着，我并不想把营地浪漫化。那是很难生活的地方。
People sometimes steal from each other and fight. But they also share resources and look out for each other. And campments definitely are communities. A few weeks after we met, Kasey told me his social worker had been out to the camp to give her an assessment for the coordinated entry system, or in other words, get her on the list. And did she tell you when you could expect to hear anything? She said, do you know where I stood on the list by Tuesday or Wednesday, so? Wow, so.
人们有时会互相偷窃和打架。但他们也分享资源，互相照顾。营地绝对是社区。在我们见面几周后，KC告诉我，她的社工曾来过营地，对她进行协调准入系统的评估，换句话说，就是让她进入名单。她有没有告诉你什么时候能听到消息？她说：“到了周二或周三，你就知道我的排名情况了，所以呢。”“哇，所以呢。”
Well, okay. I didn't know then, but of course, I know now that the list isn't a waiting list, but a ranking system. It's a list of thousands of homeless people in the county sorted according to their score on a vulnerability assessment. There were a number of things about Casey that made it likely she'd end up toward the top of the list. For the last several years, she'd been moving into increasingly dangerous and difficult living conditions. Until finally, she had ended up where she was now, just feet from a busy interstate off ramp. Her body was worn down and injured from a lifetime
好吧，行。我当时并不知道，但当然，我现在知道了，那份名单不是等待名单，而是一个排名系统。它是该县成千上万无家可归者的名单，根据他们在脆弱性评估中的得分进行排序。凯西身上有许多因素使她很有可能最终排在名单的前列。在过去的几年里，她一直搬进日益危险和艰难的生活环境中。直到最后，她终于到了现在这个地方，距离一条繁忙的州际公路匝道只有几英尺远。大半生的艰难生活和十年的无家可归，让她的身体磨损和受伤。
of hard living and a decade of homelessness. Along the way she'd accumulated many so-called vulnerabilities, a criminal record, a history of drug abuse, an injured knee that meant she could barely walk. There were other vulnerabilities too. So many, the casee did, indeed, become one of the handful of people at the top of the list in Alameda County. Do you have AC in here? Yeah, do you have a minute to turn it on? Yeah, can we do that instead of windows just for the sound? I'm riding around in the car with McCune Regurum while he runs errands. McCune is a case worker at Casey's doctor's office, a place called Lifelong Medical Care. 600 feet, turn right onto 41st Street.
在这个过程中，她积累了许多所谓的脆弱点：犯罪记录、吸毒史、膝盖受伤导致她几乎无法走路。还有其他的脆弱点。有那么多，以至于凯西确实成为了阿拉米达县名列前茅的少数几个人之一。“你这里有空调吗？”“是的，你有空把它打开吗？”“好吧，我们可以用这个代替开窗户，只是为了隔音？”我和麦昆·雷古姆（McCune Regurum）一起坐在车里，他正在跑腿办事。麦昆是凯西医生诊所的一名个案经理，那个地方叫“终身医疗护理”（Lifelong Medical Care）。“600英尺后，右转进入41st街。”
Lifelong Medical Care recently decided to dip its toes into the world of housing because they realized that in many cases they couldn't address their homeless patient's health concerns without first addressing their housing concerns. If a lifelong patient needs housing, Macoon can help make sure that person gets into the coordinated entry system. But then he just has to hope they make it to the top of the list. They don't always.
“终身医疗护理”最近决定涉足住房领域，因为他们意识到，在许多情况下，如果不首先解决无家可归患者的住房问题，他们就无法解决患者的健康问题。如果终身医疗护理的患者需要住房，麦昆可以帮助确保这个人进入协调准入系统。但随后他只能希望他们能排到名单的前列。他们并不总是能排到。
Even people in really difficult circumstances, which is frustrating. I am frustrated because I have a patient with Parkinson's who is sleeping outside right now and he's not eligible for any permanent supportive housing. Casey though, she had moved so far up the list that she was eligible for that rare and coveted intervention permanent supportive housing. The permanent part means that Casey can keep it forever. And the supportive part means that in addition
即使是处境非常艰难的人也是如此，这令人沮丧。我很沮丧，因为我有一个患有帕金森氏症的患者现在睡在外面，而且他没有资格获得任何永久性支持性住房。然而，凯西却在名单上上升得很高，以至于她有资格获得那种罕见且令人艳羡的干预措施——永久性支持性住房。“永久性”意味着凯西可以永远拥有它。“支持性”意味着除了住房补贴外，
to the housing subsidy, she'll get a bunch of extra help, access to things like therapy or in-home care, and a case worker who's helping her navigate everything. Are you guys working with anyone else that lives in Casey's encampment? I'm not personally. Yeah. It feels like a lot of people there could potentially use
她还会得到一堆额外的帮助，比如获得治疗或居家护理等服务的机会，以及一个帮她应对一切事务的个案经理。“你们有没有和住在凯西营地的其他人合作？”“我个人没有。”“感觉那里很多人潜在地都可能需要”
one of these permanent supportive housing vouchers. Permanent supportive housing vouchers are expensive. In the range of about $30,000 a year per person and there aren't enough for everyone, which is why only a few hundred people at the top of the list in Alameda County will get one of these every year. But to actually get the voucher,
其中一张永久性支持性住房代金券。永久性支持性住房代金券很贵。每人每年大约3万美元，而且数量不够所有人分配，这就是为什么阿拉米达县排在名单前列的区区几百人每年才能拿到其中一张。但要真正拿到代金券，
Macoon will have to submit tons of paperwork and actual proof that Casey is chronically homeless, meaning she's disabled and she's been homeless for a long time. You have to provide monthly evidence of interaction with a person. In cases where there isn't a paper trail documenting someone's homelessness over the years, Makoon will occasionally have to gather witness statements. I can tell you right now, I've been around lousy caseworkers while doing this reporting who I would not want representing me in this laborious paperwork effort.
麦昆必须提交大量的文书工作和实际证据，证明凯西是长期无家可归者，这意味着她残疾且已经无家可归很长时间了。你必须提供与一个人互动的每月证据。在没有纸质记录证明某人多年无家可归的情况下，麦昆有时不得不收集目击者的证词。我現在就可以告诉你，在做这篇报道时，我遇到过糟糕的个案经理，我绝不希望他们在这种繁琐的文书工作努力中代表我。
But Macoon is not that. Macoon is young and he looks it, but I still found him intimidating to interview. He's completely impervious to charming reporters and other needless distractions. It seemed like Casey was in good hands, but even beyond all the paperwork, there would be one final hurdle, actually finding a place for her to live. It's really hard to find a decent place in Berkeley with a voucher. If you do find a place in Berkeley with a voucher, they tend not to be the nicest places. But Berkeley was the only place Casey wanted to be.
但麦昆不是那样的人。麦昆很年轻，看起来也是如此，但我发现采访他仍然很有压力的。他完全对有魅力的记者和其他不必要的干扰免疫。看起来凯西得到了很好的照顾，但除了所有的文书工作之外，还有一个最后的障碍，那就是真正为她找到一个居住的地方。在伯克利凭代金券找到一个像样的房子真的很难。如果你确实在伯克利凭代金券找到了地方，它们往往也不是最好的地方。但伯克利是凯西唯一想呆的地方。
There it goes. One bedroom rent includes utilities, water, electricity, gas, and trash and internet. There's a washing machine and dryer. One day shortly after she found out she had been matched with a housing voucher. I stopped by Casey's tent and found her looking at Kreik's list. Casey hadn't looked at apartments for a long time, but the voucher she was matched with could be used to rent an apartment on the private market.
就是这个。一居室，租金包含水电费、水费、电费、燃气费、垃圾处理费和互联网。有洗衣机和烘干机。有一天，在她得知自己与住房代金券匹配后不久。我顺便去了凯西的帐篷，发现她正在看Craigslist网站。凯西已经很久没有看公寓了，但与她匹配的代金券可以用来在私人市场上租一套公寓。
And does it say anything about vouchers? No, it doesn't. Yeah. A lot of landlords don't accept housing vouchers, although it's illegal not to, so they don't come right out and say it on Craigslist. In any case, pickings are slim and Berkeley. That's place in the way of Anisha. Would you ever consider it? come right out and say it on Craigslist. In any case, pickings are slim and Berkeley.
“上面有提到代金券吗？”“没有，上面没有。”是的。很多房东不接受住房代金券，尽管不接受是违法的，所以他们不会直接在Craigslist上说出来。无论如何，伯克利的选择寥寥无几。那是通往比内沙（Benicia）的地方。你考虑过吗？直接在Craigslist上说出来。无论如何，伯克利的选择寥寥无几。
That's place in the way of Anisha. Would you ever consider it? I would have known, I have no support system there, and no friends, no no help. Not only did Casey not want to move to Colorado, she didn't want to move to the relatively close cities of Vallejo or Binesha. She wanted to stay in Berkeley as close to the encampment as possible. Kasey had been homeless for close to a decade, which was probably what helped her get to
那是通往比内沙的地方。你会考虑吗？我才知道，我在那里没有支持系统，没有朋友，没有……没有帮助。凯西不仅不想搬到科罗拉多，她也不想搬到相对较近的瓦列霍（Vallejo）或比内沙市。她想呆在伯克利，离营地越近越好。凯西已经无家可归近十年了，这可能正是帮助她登上
the top of the list. But it was also, in a way, what would make it hard for her to actually get inside. For years, she had been depending on the people around her for support. And moving into housing would mean leaving them behind. Still, sometimes with Casey, I had trouble understanding if by insisting on staying in Berkeley, she was being prudent or obstinate or both. I mean, do you ever, like, I'm back in the car with McCune,
名单前列的原因。但在某种程度上，这也是使她难以真正搬进室内的原因。多年来，她一直依赖周围的人给予支持。搬进住房意味着把他们抛在身后。尽管如此，有时对凯西来说，我很难理解她坚持留在伯克利究竟是出于谨慎、顽固还是两者兼有。我的意思是，你有没有觉得……我又回到了麦昆的车里，
trying to get out an awkward question? When someone is, is, is unhappy like unhappy like that do ever feel like they're being they're being too picky? I think it's natural to feel that sometimes. I think like potentially people that listen to this could think like well I can't afford to live in Berkeley like I had to leave Berkeley because I couldn't afford it. Yeah. Why should someone insist on staying in this really expensive place? I think the answer is you can have your preferences and KC has your preferences. And also, when we're talking about listeners who are like, I want to live in Berkeley, I mean, you too can live in Berkeley if you are homeless for five to six years.
试图抛出一个尴尬的问题？当有人对现状感到不高兴时，你是否会觉得他们太挑剔了？我认为有时有这种感觉是很自然的。我想，可能会听这个节目的听众会觉得，嗯，我也负担不起在伯克利的生活，我不得不离开伯克利，因为我负担不起。是的。为什么有人要坚持留在这个非常昂贵的地方？我认为答案是，你可以有你的偏好，KC也有她的偏好。而且，当我们谈论那些心想“我也想住在伯克利”的听众时，我的意思是，如果你无家可归五到六年，你也可以住在伯克利。
And are lucky enough to get matched up with one of these vouchers. Like, yeah, you'd be my guest. Point again. Right, like this is not the kind of opportunity that you live a happy life and still receive. But it turned out maybe Casey wouldn't have to leave Berkeley to move indoors. Mccoon had another option. He'd found an apartment that he thought could work for Casey in a place called the Amistad House. It's a building for seniors and disabled adults. And if they could get all the paperwork together, K.C. could get what's called a project-based voucher.
并且足够幸运能与其中一张代金券匹配。就像，请便吧。说得对。对吧，这绝不是那种你过着幸福生活还能得到的机会。但事实证明，也许凯西不需要离开伯克利就能搬进室内。麦昆有了另一个选择。他在一个叫做阿米斯达之屋（Amistad House）的地方为凯西找到了一套他认为可以行的公寓。这是一栋专为老年人和残疾成年人建造的大楼。如果他们能把所有的文书工作都凑齐，KC就可以拿到所谓的项目基准代金券。
Meaning the voucher was still permanent, but it would stay with the building. So if she decided to leave that place, she'd lose it. That was a downside. But McCoon said the building was beautiful and well maintained. And best of all, for Casey, it wasn't Berkeley. The next time I see Casey, she's in her tent, sitting slouched on her bed,
这意味着代金券依然是永久性的，但它会跟随着这栋建筑。所以如果她决定离开那个地方，她就会失去它。这是一个缺点。但麦昆说这栋建筑很漂亮，维护得很好。最棒的是，对凯西来说，它在伯克利。我下一次见到凯西时，她正坐在帐篷里的床上，驼着背，
with a bunch of tarot cards spread out in front of her. She looks worried, and she says she has reservations about the Amistad. So tell me what your reservations are about the... I just think my music is too loud, I'm too loud. But you're gonna try it? No, no, no, no, no. Try it.
面前摊开了一堆塔罗牌。她看起来很担忧，并表示她对阿米斯达之屋有所保留。所以告诉我你对……有什么保留意见？我只是觉得我的音乐声音太大了，我太吵了。但你要试试吗？不，不，不，不，不。试试看。
That means I'll be back out here again. Does you think like you might get kicked out of there? Is that what your worry is? Yeah, always. Always. Have you gotten kicked out of other places for being the wrong kind of tenants? No, they never lived in those kind of places. I just can't see me doing the things I want to do. And you don't feel willing to kind of adjust your lifestyle to this new place. Just like my lifestyle, you mean change who I am? And what I do?
那意味着我又得回到这里来了。你觉得你可能会被那里赶出来吗？这就是你所担心的吗？是的，总是这样。总是这样。你有没有因为当了不对劲的租客而被其他地方赶出来过？没有，我从来没住过那种地方。我只是觉得我没法做我想做的事。而且你觉得不愿意为这个新地方调整一下你的生活方式？就像我的生活方式，你的意思是改变我是谁？还有我做的事？
I don't think I can do that. Well, just not change who you are, but maybe change the volume at which you play your music or something like that. That's on the front. That's not a, no there. Casey seemed worried that her lifestyle wasn't going to be a good fit for the Amistad, but really 90% of the time when I stopped by her tent this year, she's just sitting in it alone, reading, not partying or playing loud music or anything like that.
我想我做不到这一点。好吧，不是改变你是谁，而是也许改变你放音乐的音量或者诸如此类的事情。那是在前面。那不是一个，不，在那儿。凯西似乎担心她的生活方式不适合阿米斯达之屋，但实际上今年我顺便去她的帐篷时，90%的时间她都只是一个人坐在里面看书，既没有开派对，也没有放很大声的音乐或做类似的事情。
To me, it seemed like she was scared. Coming up with the reasons it wasn't going to work. Breaking up with them before they could break up with her. But it worried me. I didn't know if Mccoon would be able to find her another apartment in Berkeley, if not this one. Or if she would ever agree to leave this hard place she thought of as home.
在我看来，她是在害怕。她一直在寻找行不通的理由。在别人抛弃她之前先甩掉别人。但这让我很担心。我不知道如果不是这套公寓的话，麦昆是否还能在伯克利为她找到另一套公寓。或者她是否会同意离开这个她认为是家的艰难地方。
Casey? Hi. How are you doing? Do you mind if I come in for a minute? A couple weeks after KC first told me she wasn't sure she wanted to move into the Amistad. I stopped by her tent to see if her feelings had changed at all. She said that Mccoon had been able to calm some of her fears. So he was reassuring. What did he say about it?
凯西？嗨。你好吗？你介意我进来一会儿吗？在KC第一次告诉我她不确定自己是否想搬进阿米斯达之屋几周后。我顺便去了她的帐篷，看看她的想法有没有什么改变。她说麦昆已经能够平息她的一些恐惧了。所以他是让人安心的。他对此是怎么说的？
Robert, they want to know how we get this thing running so we can help you stuck inside this car. KC has an electric wheelchair, but someone stole the battery out of it and it hasn't been functional for a while. I think it's hard for KC to an electric wheelchair, but someone stole the battery out of it, and it hasn't been functional for a while. I think it's hard for KC to be as dependent as she is on other people, and she's emotional as she talks about it. So he said you guys would try to get your wheelchair running so that you could feel like you could come and go. I know.
罗伯特，他们想知道我们怎么把这东西弄动起来，这样我们就能帮你被困在这辆车里了。凯西有一辆电动轮椅，但有人把上面的电池偷了，它已经有一段时间无法运作了。我想凯西很难……电动轮椅，但有人把上面的电池偷了，它已经有一段时间无法运作了。我想凯西很难像现在这样依赖其他人，她在谈论这件事时情绪激动。所以他说你们会设法让你的轮椅动起来，这样你就能觉得你可以自如出行了。我知道。
I wouldn't be without support. Mrs. Dan was told in a comfortable little that. At least I have friends who support. This place is damp and cold and uncomfortable, but at least I have friends and support. This reminds me of one of my early conversations with Casey. She told me, solving homelessness felt complicated. I really do. I admire anybody who rolls out their sleeves
如果没有支持，我就不会在这里。太太说在一个舒适的小……至少我有支持我的朋友。这个地方又潮湿又冷又不舒服，但至少我有朋友和支持。这让我想起了我早期和凯西的一次对话。她告诉我，解决无家可归问题感觉很复杂。“我真的……我钦佩任何卷起袖子试图啃下这块硬骨头的人，我真的钦佩。”
and tries to take that job out and I really do. What strikes you as being so complicated about it, like, is it... Finding housing for men, then the people who can't, who just, there are people that they're romantically, cannot be alone. They can't. They survive in our homeless communities because we make rooms for them and make sure they go right. Casey went on to give me an example.
什么事让你觉得这么复杂，比如，是……为人们寻找住房，然后是那些不能，那些人，他们从浪漫意义上说，不能独处。他们不能。他们在我们的无家可归社区中生存，因为我们为他们腾出空间并确保他们走对路。”凯西接着给我举了一个例子。
She said there was a guy at the landfill named Sparky. He was reclusive and Casey thought likely dealing with schizophrenia. But there were a few people in the community who looked out for him, including her. He would sometimes come into her house wet and cold and she'd have a pair of pants for him and clean socks. Yeah, you can't just discard people because, look, if you have a set of priceless dishes and one plate has a fine hairline crack in it.
她说垃圾填埋场里有一个叫斯帕基（Sparky）的家伙。他离群索居，凯西认为他可能患有精神分裂症。但社区里有几个人照顾他，包括她。他有时会湿漉漉、冷冰冰地走进她的屋子，她会为他准备一条裤子和干净的袜子。“是的，你不能只是把人抛弃，因为，看，如果你有一套无价的餐具，其中一个盘子有一道细微的裂纹。”
And you know that you don't give that to just anybody sitting on the table, you don't just let it. And you know that that, you don't give that to just anybody sitting on the table. You don't send it to the kid's table, you know. You think that you always end up with that plate because you're the one who knows not to hit it too hard with your life. I'm not to drop the fork in it. Because even though that plate is flawed,
你知道你不会把那个盘子随便给坐在桌边的任何人，你不会就那样……你知道，那个，你不会把它随便给坐在桌边的任何人。你不会把它送到儿童桌旁，你知道的。你觉得你最终总是会用那个盘子，因为你是那个知道不要在生活中对它下手太重的人。我知道不要把叉子掉在上面。因为尽管那个盘子有瑕疵，
that plate is part of the set. Right? Okay. And that was Sparky. That was Sparky. Okay. And that was Sparky. That was Sparky. That was Sparky, but these days it's also KC.
那个盘子也是这套餐具的一部分。对吧？好的。那个人就是斯帕基。那个人就是斯帕基。好的。那个人就是斯帕基。那个人就是斯帕基。那个人曾经是斯帕基，但如今也是KC。
KC survives with a lot of help from the people around her. She needs a lot of care and she has to be handled somewhat delicately. Fine China with a crack in it is a pretty good metaphor for vulnerability. The intervention that works for people who need a lot of extra care. People like Sparky and Casey is fortunately the exact one Casey was matched up with. Permanent supportive housing with no sobriety tests, no barriers. It's the approach that Samson Barris developed all those years ago in New York, and that Mccoon is now carrying on here in Berkeley.
KC在周围人的大量帮助下生存下来。她需要很多照顾，而且必须小心翼翼地对待。带有裂纹的精美瓷器是形容脆弱性的一个相当不错的隐喻。幸运的是，对于那些需要大量额外照顾的人——像斯帕基和凯西这样的人——起作用的干预措施，正是凯西与之匹配的那一种。没有戒酒测试、没有障碍的永久性支持性住房。这就是山姆·巴里斯（Samson Barris）多年前在纽约开发的方法，也是麦昆现在正在伯克利延续的方法。
And it works. In Alameda County, when people are lucky enough to be unlucky enough to get this type of housing, the data shows they hold onto it for a long time. Hello. Hi, KC. Hi. The process of getting KC the apartment at the Amistad was a long one. Lots of paperwork, lots of back and forth between KC and Macooned.
而且它确实管用。在阿拉米达县，当人们足够幸运地倒霉到能分到这种类型的住房时，数据显示他们会长期保留它。你好。嗨，KC。嗨。为KC争取阿米斯达之屋公寓的过程很漫长。大量的文书工作，KC和麦昆之间大量的来回沟通。
And I don't know that there was an exact moment. When KC finally decided she was going to accept the place. I think it was more the Mccooned inched her there little by little. And now it was finally almost time to move in. Dropping off the check next Wednesday, moving the Monday after that. So I don't think I got a chance to tell you the time it's at 11 a.m. is when we're signing the lease. Casey was still scared, but she was also excited and genuinely grateful to McHoon. She told me she knew she had not always been easy to work with, but McHoon did stuck by her
我不知道是否存在这样一个确切的时刻：当KC终于决定她要接受这个地方。我觉得更像是麦昆一点一点地引导她走到了那里。现在终于快到搬家的时候了。下周三去交支票，再随后的那个星期一搬家。所以我想我之前没有机会告诉你具体时间，我们是在上午11点签租约。凯西还是很害怕，但她也很兴奋，并且由衷地感激麦昆。她告诉我，她知道自己并不总是那么好相处，但麦昆一直坚定而有耐心地陪在她身边。
steady and patient. You're in good hands then I didn't know it then. I do now. Thanks, Casey. You're welcome. On the end of time. I'm beginning less anxious and more happy all the time. That's very dangerous.
“那你当时就得到照顾了。”“我当时不知道。我现在知道了。谢谢你，凯西。”“不客气。”随着时间的推移。我越来越不焦虑，而且一直都很高兴。这太危险了。
Makoon told me that if Casey had turned down the Amistad, there might not have been anywhere for her to live in Berkeley. And then they would have had to talk about what was more important to her. Housing or staying close to her community. And maybe Casey would have actually chosen to stay homeless in the encampment. I don't think everyone would make that choice, but I think there's a good chance Casey would have. And McCoon said he would have had to let go of his own feelings about what he should or shouldn't do, which makes me think about something Sam Semberis always says when he talks about the work he was doing with housing first in New York.
麦昆告诉我，如果凯西拒绝了阿米斯达之屋，她在伯克利可能就无处可去了。然后他们就不得不讨论什么对她更重要：是住房，还是留在她的社区附近。也许凯西真的会选择继续在营地里无家可归。我不认为每个人都会做这种选择，但我认为凯西很有可能会这么做。麦昆说他将不得不放下他自己关于他应该或不应该做什么的感觉，这让我想起山姆·森贝里斯（Sam Semberis）在谈论他在纽约开展“住房优先”工作时总是说的一句话：
It was never about the housing. It was always about the choice. The only other person I heard had made it to the top of the list for housing while I was reporting on Casey's encampment was a woman who went by the nickname Mama Bear. Like Casey, she also had very limited mobility. And so, as Casey had started housing,
这从来都不是关于住房的问题。这永远都是关于选择的问题。在我报道凯西的营地期间，我听说的另一个成功排到住房名单前列的人是一位昵称叫“熊妈妈”（Mama Bear）的女士。和凯西一样，她的行动能力也非常有限。所以，正如凯西开始着手住房一样，
there are at least 70 people still living in her encampment. What do you think about Casey getting housing? I'm glad. I'm talking with Sarah. This is a different Sarah than the one who was trying to get Casey pallets in the rain. This Sarah also lives here in Casey's encampment, and she's an old friend who lived at the landfill.
她的营地里依然至少有70人在生活。你对凯西获得住房有什么看法？我很高兴。我正在和莎拉交谈。这不是那个在雨中试图帮凯西拿木托盘的莎拉。这个莎拉也住在凯西的营地里，她是住在垃圾填埋场的老朋友。
She's mostly happy to see Casey getting some help. She's limited in handicapped, whatever you want to call it, but she needs housing. So did Mama Bear. She finally got it. I want housing, but she needs housing. So did Mama Bear, she finally got it. I want housing, but I don't need it like they do. But I think it would, I think living on the street at my age 53, it's gonna shorten my life. And does it like, when you see somebody
她大多为凯西能得到一些帮助感到高兴。“她行动有限，残疾，无论你怎么称呼它，但她需要住房。”熊妈妈也是如此。她终于得到了。我想要住房，但她需要住房。熊妈妈也是如此，她终于得到了。我想要住房，但我不需要像他们那样。不过我想，以我53岁的年纪住在街上，会缩短我的寿命。当你看到一个
that you know, get housing, like do you feel just happy or do you feel any jealousy? I'm 99.9% just happy for them. There's a little tiny sliver of, it's modest humble jealousy, but more whistfulness, I guess. So, I'm not really a jealous person, but every now and then there's somebody who is really Challenges a human being who gets housing and then I'm like why the hell is someone like that get out? But you know, I know it's rational Many of the people in this encampment have probably had a vulnerability assessment at some point. Many of them are dealing with challenges like mental or physical illness.
你认识的人获得了住房，你心里是纯粹的高兴，还是会有一点嫉妒？我99.9%都是为他们感到高兴。有一小点点，这是一种谦卑的嫉妒，但我想更多的是一种向往吧。所以，我其实不是一个嫉妒心强的人，但偶尔确实会有某个真正经受考验、挑战人性的家伙得到了住房，然后我就想：凭什么像那种人能得到房子？不过你知道的，我知道这很理性。这个营地的许多人可能在某个时候都进行过脆弱性评估。他们中的许多人正在应对精神或身体疾病等挑战。
Some are struggling with addiction. But the bar is just so high now in Alameda County. You have to be able to check so many boxes to get any help. For the people like Sarah who remain in the encampment, their hope is just to be able to stay here in peace without the constant threat of being swept out by cow trans and having their belongings confiscated. It's this place, right? There's this spot right here. On the day of the lease signing, Casey and McEun and I drive to the Amistad House together. It's a 60-unit building with the dark wooden shingles that are typical in Berkeley, on a quiet tree-lined street. Kasey is
有些人正在与毒瘾作斗争。但在阿拉米达县，门槛实在是太高了。你必须符合无数的条件才能得到任何帮助。对于像莎拉这样留在营地里的人来说，他们的愿望只是能在这里平静地生活，而不用时刻面临被加州交通局驱逐并没收财物的威胁。就是这个地方，对吧？就在这里。在签租约的那天，凯西、麦昆和我一起驱车前往阿米斯坦德公寓。这是一栋有60个单元的建筑，带有伯克利典型的深色木制瓦片，坐落在一条安静的林荫街道上。凯西
wearing her best dress, a black lacy one that is both old lady classy and a little goth. How you feeling? Moooooo! What a nice looking building! Kasey hasn't actually seen the apartment she's gonna be moving into yet. Although she's seen a similar one in the same building. It's hanging up. A lobby in touch, she's ready. We wait in the lobby where there's a couch and a fireplace and a sleepy security guard looking at his phone. Casey seems incredibly nervous. Oh, a fainter.
穿着她最好的裙子，一条黑色蕾丝裙，既有老太太的高贵，又带有一点哥特风。感觉怎么样？哞——！多么漂亮的一栋建筑！凯西实际上还没看过她将要搬进去的公寓。尽管她看过同一栋楼里类似的公寓。它挂在上面。大堂很温馨，她准备好了。我们在大堂等待，那里有沙发、壁炉和一个看着手机的昏昏欲睡的保安。凯西看起来非常紧张。哦，一个要晕倒的人。
You're a fainter? Yeah. Are you feeling fainting? Yeah. Oh, a painter. You're a painter? Yeah. Are you feeling faint? Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, we never wrote it up. It's just like hitting this. Put your head between down a little bit.
你容易晕倒吗？是的。你觉得头晕吗？是的。哦，一个画家。你是个画家吗？是的。你觉得头晕吗？是的。哦，是的。哦，我们从来没记下来。这就像是撞击了这个。把头稍微放低一点。
I'll bring you there for her. Eventually, Casey is called into the management office, where she signs the lease and a bunch of other papers. And then finally, she gets to see her place. We ride the elevator to the third floor and then make our way down a hallway. It's just the first door on the right, so if you go through that second door. Okay, so... The apartment is one bedroom and certainly not fancy, but it's really nice, well maintained,
我替你把她带过去。最终，凯西被叫进管理办公室，她在那里签署了租约和一堆其他文件。最后，她终于看到了她的住处。我们乘电梯到三楼，然后沿着走廊走去。右边的第一扇门就是，如果你穿过第二扇门。好的，那么……这间公寓是一居室，当然算不上豪华，但非常漂亮，保养得很好，
and it has a balcony that looks into a courtyard full of trees. Fully painted, fresh paint in the unit. I put brand new granite countertops, appliances, you do have like a garbage disposal. While the building manager lists the amenities, KC is taking deep breaths and talking to her dog, Eva. When she sees the kitchen, she says, remember when I used to cook? I'm gonna use the cook.
而且有一个阳台，可以看到长满树木的庭院。完全刷过漆，单元里有新刷的油漆。我换上了崭新的花岗岩台面、家电，你们确实有垃圾处理机。当物业经理列出设施时，凯西深吸了一口气，并和她的狗伊娃说话。当她看到厨房时，她说，还记得我以前做饭的时候吗？我要用这个锅。
And I get triaths out of him and you. Your patio does overlook the garden area too. And the triaths out of me. Whew. Before we leave, the building manager hands Casey a set of keys for her place. And that's it. Casey tries the keys out in the door, they work, and then we take her back to her tent
我能从你和他那得到三项铁人赛。你的露台也可以俯瞰花园区。还有我这里的三项铁人赛。呼。在我们离开之前，物业经理把她住处的一把钥匙交给了凯西。就是这样。凯西把钥匙插进门里试了试，管用，然后我们把她带回了她的帐篷
and drop her off. She has at least now. The place is really hers, but she's not going to stay in it tonight. And maybe by this point, I shouldn't have been surprised by this, but I was. I mean, okay, yeah. The furniture and macooned order hasn't arrived yet, but Kasey could bring over the bed she has in her tent and just make it work until the furniture gets there. The apartment has electricity and hot water and a door that locks.
并把她放下。她现在至少有地方住了。这个地方真正属于她了，但她今晚不打算呆在那里。也许到了这个时候，我不应该对此感到惊讶，但我确实很惊讶。我的意思是，好吧，是的。麦昆订购的家具还没到，但凯西可以把她在帐篷里的床搬过来，先凑合着用，直到家具送到。公寓里有电、热水和一扇能锁上的门。
The camp doesn't have any of that. But Kasey says no, no, no, she doesn't want her old crummy bed in the new apartment. She wants to start fresh with a new bed. In retrospect, this makes sense, not just that she doesn't want her old bed, but that she's going to do even this final step on her own terms. For the next few weeks, Casey takes small loads of stuff over to the Amistad. Finally, nearly a month after signing the lease, she sleeps in her new apartment for the first time. But a few days later, when I call to check in,
营地可没有这些。但凯西说不，不，不，她不想把她破旧的老床搬进新公寓。她想用一张新床重新开始。回想起来，这说得通，不仅是因为她不想要旧床，还因为她要按自己的方式完成这最后一步。在接下来的几周里，凯西把一小箱一小箱的东西搬到阿米斯坦德。最后，在签署租约近一个月后，她第一次睡在了新公寓里。但几天后，当我打电话去探视时，
see how it's going, Casey is in tears. She wants to go home to the encampment, she tells me. So your place doesn't feel like home yet? Nope. There's a bunch monster empty car boxes. But then things get better. The other people in the building are friendly to her. They don't seem to find her strange like she feared.
看情况怎么样，凯西泪流满面。她告诉我，她想回营地去。所以你的新地方还没让你觉得像个家？没有。有一堆大号的空纸箱。但后来情况好转了。楼里的其他人对她很友好。他们似乎并不觉得她像她所害怕的那样奇怪。
She starts therapy, taking advantage of the supportive part of her permanent supportive housing voucher. She finds she loves the luxury of a hot bath whenever she wants it. And probably more important than all of that. Friends come from the camp, which is just a couple miles away to help her set up her place and make it feel like home. After the break, some final thoughts and updates of the people you met in this series. It's been nine months since Casey moved into her apartment and she's doing great. Her son Lonnie came from Colorado to visit for her birthday. It was her first time ever being able to host him. You guys are here and your mom has a house.
她开始接受心理治疗，利用她的永久支持性住房券带来的支持服务。她发现自己很喜欢随时享受热水澡的奢侈。可能比这一切都更重要的是。朋友们从几英里外的营地赶来，帮她布置住处，让她觉得这里像个家。休息之后，是一些最后的想法以及你在这部系列片中遇到的人的近况。距离凯西搬进公寓已经过去九个月了，她过得很好。她的儿子洛尼从科罗拉多赶来给她过生日。这是她第一次能够招待他。你们都在这儿，你妈妈有房子了。
Yes, housed. Yay! Yay, Rupel over her head. And it's a pretty place. Isn't it nice? That's right. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you.
是的，有房了。耶！耶，头顶上有个屋顶了。而且是个不错的地方。不是很漂亮吗？没错。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。
Happy Birthday dear KC. Happy Birthday to you. And many more. And many more. Hungl enough. A lot has happened back at KC's old encampment too. The people living there decided next time CalTrans crews asked them to move, they weren't going to comply.
祝亲爱的凯西生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。福寿绵长。福寿绵长。好饿。凯西的老营地也发生了很大变化。住在那里的人决定，下次加州交通局的工作人员要求他们搬迁时，他们将不再服从。
Instead of grabbing all their stuff and moving like they always did, the plan was to stay put in their tents. I have some tape of the day they decided to try this. CalTrans workers had arrived at the encampment in a procession of dump trucks accompanied by the highway patrol and the residents of the encampment were in a kind of standoff with them. Hey, Osha. What's going on over here right now? I don't know.
他们没有像往常那样收拾所有东西然后搬走，而是计划呆在帐篷里不动。我有一些他们决定尝试这一天的录像。加州交通局的工作人员在一队自卸卡车的护送下抵达了营地，随行的还有公路巡警，营地居民与他们形成了一种对峙状态。嘿，奥沙。这会儿这边发生什么事了？我不知道。
I was standing with Ocean Newman, an 80-year-old lawyer who's advocated for the rights of homeless people in Berkeley for decades. He's known Casey since her days living at the landfill. Back when everyone was forced to leave that community, Oshah was there helping them fight to stay. Over the years, he's watched these encampment sweeps and evictions countless times. Are there always as many of them as the CalTrans people and the highway patrol people? There are always this many CalTrans people, yeah.
我当时正和奥沙·纽曼站在一起，他是一位80岁的律师，几十年来一直为伯克利无家可归者的权利大声疾呼。自从凯西住在垃圾填埋场的日子起，他就认识她了。当年每个人都被迫离开那个社区时，奥沙就在那里帮助他们争取留下的权利。多年来，他无数次目睹了这些营地清场和驱逐行动。加州交通局的人和公路巡警总是这么多人吗？加州交通局的人总是这么多，是的。
I am thinking they're leaving. They are leaving. They're leaving. I'll be damned. They're leaving. I'll be damned. They're leaving. They they aren't going to move people. They're leaving. They had this was bigger than they expected. This is kind of incredible. They're leaving. They're leaving. Oh my God. Has this never happened before? Oh my God, never, never before. There's never been resistance.
我猜他们要走了。他们要走了。他们要走了。我真不敢相信。他们要走了。我真不敢相信。他们要走了。他们不打算赶走人了。他们要走了。这比他们预期的要大。这简直不可思议。他们要走了。他们要走了。我的天哪。以前从来没有发生过这种事吗？哦，天哪，从来没有，以前从来没有。从来没有过抵抗。
They're leaving. Oh my God. Tell me why this feels so big to you. Oh, it's incredible. It never has happened before that people have resisted. That people on the street resisted and won. It just has never happened. They've always moved. Every time they've been pushed around, they've moved, they've moved, and they're telling them, whoa!
他们要走了。哦，天哪。告诉我为什么这让你觉得这么震撼。哦，太不可思议了。以前从来没有发生过人们进行抵抗的事。街头的人进行抵抗并且赢了。这真的是从来没有发生过。他们总是搬走。每次他们被驱赶，他们就搬走，他们就搬走，他们告诉他们，哇！
But aren't they just going to come back next week? Who knows? Of course! You never have the one victory that's the final. The war is never over completely. The war in fact lasted several months. There were meetings and negotiations and ultimately a city council vote, but in the end the encampment residents basically won. They got cow trans to stop the sweeps, and they got the city of Berkeley to commit to establishing a sanctioned encampment for them. Meaning people would be legally allowed to pitch tents, and trash service and restrooms would be provided. So far the sweeps have stopped, but the plans for a sanctioned encampment seemed to have stalled out since the start of the pandemic. the start of the pandemic. Who else? Michael, my neighbor, who lived on the boat.
但他们下周不会又回来了吗？谁知道呢！当然不会！你永远不会获得一次性的最终胜利。战争永远不会完全结束。事实上，这场战争持续了几个月。经过会议、谈判和最终的市议会投票，但最终露宿者营地的居民基本上赢了。他们让考尔·特兰斯停止了清场，并让伯克利市承诺为他们建立一个获得批准的露宿营地。这意味着人们将被合法允许搭建帐篷，并将提供垃圾服务和洗手间。到目前为止，清场已经停止，但建立经批准的营地的计划自大流行开始以来似乎陷入了停滞。大流行开始。还有谁？迈克尔，我的邻居，他住在船上。
He actually left the boat and moved into a program that he's hoping will eventually get him connected to housing. If you heard the housing first story, you probably remember me talking about what all housing programs used to look like, the staircase model, where you have to be clean and sober to graduate each next step. That's the type of program Michael is doing now. They still exist and they're generally led by faith-based organizations and don't receive funding from HUD. Michael is hoping he can stick with it and make it into housing.
他实际上离开了那艘船，搬进了一个他希望最终能帮他找到住房的项目。如果你听过“住房优先”的故事，你可能还记得我讲过所有住房项目过去的样子，也就是阶梯式模型，在那里你必须保持清洁和戒毒才能晋升到下一个阶段。这就是迈克尔现在正在做的项目。它们仍然存在，通常由宗教组织领导，不接受HUD的资助。迈克尔希望他能坚持下去并搬进住房。
And lastly, there's Tullisha and Jordan. Hi, kitty, I'm Yums. Okay, you tell him. Say something. I can't. You could just call it and pick it up. There's actually been a pretty big development in Tullisha and Jordan's's story. Tleysha never got help from the system here in Oakland, but something else happened. So eight years ago, before Tleysha was even homeless, she put her name on a bunch of
最后是图利莎和乔丹。嗨，小猫，我是雅姆斯。好吧，你告诉他。说点什么。我不能。你可以直接打过去然后接听。图利莎和乔丹的故事其实有了相当大的进展。蒂莉莎从未在这里的奥克兰体系中获得过帮助，但发生了别的事情。所以在八年前，在蒂莉莎甚至还没有无家可归之前，她在许多
wait lists for Section 8. Section 8, or housing choice, as it's now called, is a government subsidized voucher that you can use to rent an apartment on the private market. You don't have to be homeless to get section 8, just low income. And last December, Tolisha found out her name had finally come up on one of those wait lists. So now since he knows, and I know,
第 8 条的候补名单上写上了她的名字。第 8 条，或者现在所称的住房选择，是一项政府补贴的代金券，可用于在私人市场上租用公寓。获得第 8 条援助并不需要无家可归，只需要低收入。去年 12 月，托利莎发现她的名字终于在其中一个候补名单上排到了。所以现在既然他知道，我也知道，
this is what we have to do in order to stop being a home nulucent, sleep in the car and go off from house to house to family members and different people. This is what we have to do. But here's the wild part. The Section 8 voucher that Tileisha got was for Louisville, Kentucky, a place she had no connection to.
这就是我们为了不再无家可归、睡在车里以及在房子之间、家人和不同的人之间辗转所必须做的事情。这就是我们必须做的事情。但最疯狂的部分是，蒂莉莎获得的第 8 条代金券是去肯塔基州路易斯维尔的，那个地方她没有任何联系。
She had only put her name on the wait list there because it was one of the few that was open in the whole country. Tileisha felt she was completely out of options in Oakland though, so she decided to leave. I don't know if I can possibly convey how unique and difficult this decision was. Despite the bay being so expensive,
她之前把名字写在那个候补名单上，只是因为那是全国少数几个开放的名单之一。不过，蒂莉莎觉得她在奥克兰已经完全没有别的选择了，所以她决定离开。我不知道我是否能表达这个决定有多么独特和艰难。尽管湾区的生活成本如此高昂，
I almost never met homeless people who were thinking about leaving. People in poverty depend intensely on their communities for support. Leaving rarely seems to feel in the realm of possibility. But Tullisha had decided she had to try.
我几乎从未遇到过考虑离开的无家可归者。处于贫困中的人们严重依赖他们的社区来获得支持。离开似乎很少在可能的范围之内。但图利莎决定她必须尝试一下。
I mean, we just been talking and thinking about all the stuff we've got to go through and travel and stuff and... Yeah? We can't do this anymore. I can't take it because people go put us out. Tired of people putting us out? Yeah.
我的意思是，我们一直在谈论和思考所有我们需要经历的事情和旅程之类的东西，并且……是啊？我们再也不能这样了。我受不了了，因为人们会把我们赶出去。厌倦了别人把我们赶出去？是的。
And so, in March of this year, as the coronavirus descended on all of us, Tilecia and Jordan started a whole new journey. This recording was made just a couple days before they left. And that's it for now, Katie. It's your age, Pete. Say 99. 99. And physical. And physical.
因此，在今年三月，随着冠状病毒降临到我们所有人身上，蒂莉西亚和乔丹开始了全新的人生旅程。这段录音是在他们离开前几天制作的。暂时就这些了，凯蒂。这是你的年龄，皮特。说99。99。还有体检。还有体检。
Here we go. Here we go. Cut tuck real. To touchy real. Forty eight hours. For eight hours. Our journey starts. A journey starts. Got protectors. Not again. Not again. Okay. He don't want to say God protect us from COVID-19. Tilecia and Jordans journey into housing was a harrowing one, and maybe someday I'll tell the whole story in more detail. But I will say that they have their own place now, and they're doing really well. It's incredible the way housing changes people's lives. For me, this new chapter of Tilecia and Jordan's story is both happy and sad.
我们走吧。我们走吧。剪裁真实。太感人了。四十八小时。四十八小时。我们的旅程开始了。旅程开始了。有保护者。不会吧。不会吧。好吧。他不想说上帝保佑我们免受2019冠状病毒病的侵害。蒂莉西亚和乔丹进入住房的旅程是痛苦的，也许有一天我会更详细地讲述整个故事。但我可以说，他们现在有了自己的地方，而且过得很好。住房改变人们生活的方式真是不可思议。对我来说，蒂莉西亚和乔丹故事的这个新篇章既快乐又悲伤。
Oakland has lost a very wonderful pair of people. Tilecia had to leave the place where she grew up, where her whole family still lives. And she was only able to do this because she'd been on a section 8 waiting list for 8 years. 8 years! Tullisha and Jordan's success in Louisville, Kentucky is far from guaranteed. It'll be hard to start a life in this new place without any real support network.
奥克兰失去了一对非常美好的人。蒂莉西亚不得不离开她成长的地方，她的整个家人依然住在那里。她之所以能做到这一点，是因为她已经在第8条候补名单上排了8年。8年！蒂莉西亚和乔丹在肯塔基州路易斯维尔的成功绝不是板上钉钉的。在这个没有真正支持网络的新地方开始生活将会很艰难。
Which is why, for me, the takeaway from Casey until he's just stories is the same. We need housing opportunities in the communities where people live. How we get there is honestly a whole different podcast. But one place we can all start and Bay Area people I'm looking at you is to be open and welcoming to low-income housing development in our neighborhoods.
这就是为什么对我来说，从凯西到蒂莉莎的故事给我的启示是一样的。我们需要在我们生活的地方为人们提供住房机会。我们如何走到这一步，老实说是一个完全不同的播客话题。但我们可以共同开始的一个地方——湾区的人们，我正看着你们——就是在我们的社区中对低收入住房开发保持开放和欢迎的态度。
Okay, that's it from me. People have been asking what organizations they can give to to support homeless folks in the Bay, and we've put together a list that you can find at 99pi.org slash need. You can also find all of the chapters of this series there. Be safe everyone. Thank you so much for listening. This chapter of According to Need was produced by me, Katie Mingle, with associate producer Abby Madan and managing editor Whitney Henry Leicester. Roman Mars is the executive producer of According to Need. In valuable editing from Lisa Pollock, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney
好了，我说的就这些了。人们一直在问他们可以向哪些组织捐款以支持湾区的无家可归者，我们整理了一份名单，您可以在99pi.org/need上找到。您还可以在那里找到本系列的所有章节。大家保重。非常感谢您的收听。本期《按需分配》由我凯蒂·明格尔制作，副制作人阿比·马丹和执行主编惠特尼·亨利·莱斯特协助制作。罗曼·马尔斯是《按需分配》的执行制作人。丽莎·波洛克、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德兰尼提供了宝贵的编辑帮助
Hall, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, and Roman Mars. Bryson Barnes was our sound engineer, fact checking by Amy Gaines, music by Sean Rale, additional music by Eric Hall, branding and designed by muchmore.io. Kurt Colstead was our digital director, additional support from Sofia Klatsger, Vivian Leigh and Chris Barube. Huge thanks to Andrea Henson and Ocean Newman,
霍尔、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、乔·罗森バーグ和罗曼·马尔斯。布莱森·巴恩斯是我们的音响工程师，艾米·盖恩斯负责事实核查，肖恩·雷尔配乐，埃里克·霍尔提供额外配乐，muchmore.io负责品牌塑造和设计。库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监，索菲亚·克拉茨格、维维安·李和克里斯·巴鲁贝提供了额外支持。非常感谢安德里亚·亨森和奥森·纽曼，
who introduced me to Casey and to Andy Well Newman, who introduced me to KC and to Andy Wellspring, who made the film about the landfill called Where Do You Go When It Rains, which I excerpted. Thanks also to Talia Husbands Hanken, Marisol Medina-Karena, Johanna Zorn, and Chelsea Miller. This chapter of According to Need is dedicated to the memory of Santa Dear Heart. According to Need is a project of 99% invisible, which is a founding proud member of radiotopia from PRX, a network of independent listener supported, artist-owned podcasts. Radio Tapioid.
他们把我引见给凯西，还有安迪·韦尔·纽曼，他把我引见给凯西和安迪·韦尔斯普林，后者制作了关于垃圾填埋场的名为《下雨时你去哪里》的纪录片，我从中摘录了片段。还要感谢塔莉亚·赫斯班兹·汉肯、玛丽索尔·梅迪纳-卡雷娜、约翰娜·佐恩和切尔西·米勒。本章《按需分配》献给圣地亚·迪尔哈特的记忆。《按需分配》是99%隐形节目（99% Invisible）的一个项目，该节目是PRX旗下独立听众支持、艺术家所有的播客网络Radiotopia的创始自豪成员。Radio Tapioid。
From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。你目前还没有关于这集节目的评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。